as any good tribute of Suzanne Collins's
the Hunger Games knows the film series
took a few creative liberties in
adapting the novels of the big screen
from adding additional scenes to
removing characters and whatever was
happening with Seneca cranes beard the
movies were definitely distinct from
their source material for better and for
worse one of the subtle shifts came in
the form of the character's looks which
tended to differ from their literary
descriptions he is how the Hunger Games
cast should really look Katniss Everdeen
Jennifer Lawrence's version of Katniss
Everdeen sported an ornate braid to
manage her long brown hair and she had
humble clothing indicative of her life
in one of Panem's less favored districts
she also had greenish blue eyes and
didn't exactly look like she'd been on
the brink of starvation and while her
ability to wield a bow and fight for her
dinner was accurate there were still
some differences to be found with her
appearance in the books the girl on fire
was described as having gray eyes and
being much shorter and more gods than
her screen counterparts but since JLo's
notorious lover french fries are such a
big part of why she's so awesome no one
seemed to care that she wasn't skin and
bones for the role even if the movie was
called The Hunger Games Peeta Mellark
the game makers filmmakers got a lot of
things right when it came to bringing
the boy with the bread to cinematic life
of actor Josh Hutcherson but they also
missed the mark on a few important
points as well in the movies Pizza has
the same dishwater blonde hair with a
medium height and the stocky build earns
the hard way by hauling flour around his
parents bakery he also had hazel peepers
and walked around without any serious
injury well until the end of Catching
Fire anyway in the books though Peter
lost his leg in the first games and had
blue eyes with wavier hair these are
just minor differences but for the team
Peter faithful they were still
significant Gale Hawthorne if there's
one character who was well matched with
his actor counterparts looks it was Liam
Hemsworth as district 12 handiest hunk
Gale Hawthorne in the film's he's a tall
alluring ly handsome and strong
gentleman with the same dark hair and
gray eyes are marked so many of the
coalminers children and he
totally passed the Katniss's cousin but
there was still a few leaps from the
source material in his depiction the
book version of the character was much
more olive toned young and lean from so
many mister meals sinner the filmmakers
stuck with lenny kravitz natural
chocolate brown eyes for his turn as
sinner and opted to add in some facial
hair and earrings to round out his looks
plus he rocked some low-key fashions and
steered clear of the capital makeup
selections save for some gold eyeliner
in the books though Katniss is fabulous
stylist was described as having green
eyes with flecks of gold scattered
throughout even without the right eye
color and a couple of extra earrings
Kravitz embodied all the swagger and
self possession that sinner called for
and then some so he was a fan favorite
despite the differences Effie Trinket
this capital escorts flair for extreme
fashion and hair appliances certainly
came through in the Hunger Games Movies
however there were still some minor
deviations from the well described
costumery and wigs Elizabeth Banks
sported throughout the retin series in
The Hunger Games of pink wig was
considered ridiculous and slid out of
place and in Catching Fire she was said
to have done the pumpkin colored
headdress rather than a canary situation
she wore on her head even though she had
a few outfit and hairstyle changes
however that was definitely Effie we saw
up there on the big screen
Haymitch Abernathy in the film's payment
was a morose disheveled alcoholic who
disgusted Katniss with his lack of
composure he also had straight blonde
locks and blue eyes and never stumbled
and fumbled his way through life in
Victor village in the books however
Haymitch was said to have dark curly
hair of the same gray eyes as his fellow
coal district alumns it was pretty easy
to forget that the hair and eye colors
were off as the mentor who decided to
shape up his act enough to help his girl
stay alive in the arena but for the
nitpickers out there
the casting choice was still a confusing
one from Rose Everdeen willow shields
turn as the little sister who
accidentally started a revolution was
convincing enough
she was slight and sweet and believable
as a girl you go to bat for however in
the books she was said to have crystal
blue eyes and weighs no more than
20 pounds soaking wet which was not the
case on screen President Snow
Donald Sutherland screen turn as
president snow was one of the biggest
changes from the written origins because
while he was menacing enough with his
refined sense of evil he didn't match
the books description of the small thin
sinister looking villain of the books
with a botched enchantment job on his
lips and snakes eyes to match the
unsettling appearance hey at least I got
the White Rose on his lapel right of
course now be a hard one to screw up
Finnick Odair whether or not some
Claflin version of Finnick Odair much
that extraordinarily good-looking muscle
man he was described to be as a matter
of subjective perspective but the
filmmaker certainly gave his frame some
consideration when casting the role not
only is he a pathetic tannin cocky but
he's also adequately redeemed by his
penchant for both shirtlessness and
sugar cubes on screen plus he clung to
his trusty Trident as tightly as he was
supposed to the most noticeable
difference from the books the fact that
his C green eyes weren't a striking on
screen and his hair was more sandy blond
than bronze as written Johanna Mason
personality-wise jena malone screen
addition of Johanna Mason was a dead
ringer for the sassy sharp tongued girl
we grew to know and love in the books
yes I'm angry you know I'm getting
totally screwed over here uh-huh the
deal was that if I win the Hunger Games
I get to live the rest of my life in
peace but as accurate as they got her
character her appearance in the films
was a little different on screen she was
lean and traditionally pretty with long
brown locks well until they were shaved
off by the capital in the books
meanwhile her eyes were set to be white
while her hair was warm of a signature
spike
she was also perceived by readers as
being more muscular seeing as she was
from the lumberjack district than all
president Alma coin Julianne Moore
screen version of president coin was
pretty faithful to the books in fact she
was a middle-aged woman with wig light
gray hair and a colorless Paolo
however she looked like she was in her
late 30s and just wore a gray wig to age
herself while the book version pegged
her for around 50 and with her silvery
eye color being a lot more distinct
foxface in The Hunger Games movie
Jacqueline Emerson's vision of foxface
had bright red hair and an aptitude for
stealth and a low-key survivalism
but she's hardly meek and
certainly couldn't be confused for an
animal in the book however she was
described as having a face which had
well fox-like features
hence Katniss's name for her anyone can
open a bottle of red hair dye and say
their fox face but to look the part is
something else entirely
fresh if Thresh had appeared as imposing
as he was written
there's no way audiences would believe
he'd been killed in one-on-one combat
with Kay so even if the latter was a
career tribute as portrayed by do
Oconee in the movie he was strong and
tough but he was also rather
approachable in size and demeanor which
made his decision to forego killing
Katniss when he had the opportunity that
much more believable meanwhile in the
book he's described as having golden
eyes standing well over six feet tall
and sporting the build of an ox from so
many days in the agriculture sector ro
ro a vocal contingent of Hunger Games
readers were up in arms about the fact
that Rou as played by a Mandela
Sternberg was portrayed as having brown
skin in the first film of course those
fans clearly misunderstood the source
material while rue was said to resemble
Katniss sisters - prim in size and
innocence she was specifically described
as being black in the book the film's
representation of the tiny feisty and
quick on her feet preteen was accurate
to the writing and gave her that same
smile that affected Katniss so in both
versions she wasn't quite as frail as
she was on paper but that's about the
only major difference to be found
otherwise she was perfect
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]